bonjour monsieur roger merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rtl france alors la
france donc été proposée est opposé à ce
projet d'accord alors la position
française n'est pas très clair puisque
on se rappelle que en 2019 emmanuel
macron avaient parié justement des
incendies qui ravagent et alors à
l'époque la forêt amazonienne le
président français qui a aussi déclaré
l'an dernier quelques jours après la
signature de cet accord qu'il ne fallait
ni naïveté libre échangiste annie néo
protectionnisme voix du mal quand même
aller à la ligne écologique française
oui il faut qu'il faut remonter à ce que
ce que sont ces accords de libre échange
le problème est le même depuis le 16e
siècle puisque c'est eux
au 16ème siècle l'angleterre a compris
qu'il fallait mieux exporter des
produits manufacturés et à importer des
matières brutes ça c'est ce qui a fait
le succès de l'angleterre et après le
succès de de l'europe et c'est un homme
des changes qui est totalement illégal
puisque le but est de maintenir les
produits et fondateur de produits bruts
dans un état de dépendance vis-à-vis des
exportateurs de produits manufacturés on
se rappelle l'exemple des relations
entre l'inde et la grande bretagne
l'inde exportant le coton qui était
manufacturés en grande bretagne qui
errait exportait des vêtements en alors
c'est cette situation ne dure jamais
bien longtemps parce que d'ailleurs il
n'y a pas d'accord de libre-échange qui
duré bien longtemps
si on prend les plus connus dans notre
histoire c'est le traiter comme des
chevaliers de 1860 avec l'angleterre ça
a duré une quinzaine d'années parce
qu'on s'est aperçu qu'on était perdant
ya forcément un perdant
alors prenons l'exemple de ski avant de
revenir à au mercosur de ce qu'a fait la
chine se lâche idée très très
intéressant puisque la chine s'est
d'abord ouvert son commerce et ses
échanges de ce qu elle a adhéré à l'om
c'est de manière à contre l'exportation
de ces produits brut importé des
produits manufacturés de
sinon mais cela s'est fait grâce à une
stratégie industrielle d'accumulation de
la technologie qui a permis à la chine
de développer sa propre puissance
industrielle le tout cela était
parfaitement appliquées notamment par
singapour qui est devenu une puissance
industrielle au début en 65 souvenez
vous elle n'avait absolument rien comme
singapour c'est s'est créé et les
chinois ou parfaitement ont théorisé
cela je vous renvoie au défi le kishore
mahbubani qui sont maintenant produites
en français les les chinois ont
parfaitement compris que cette idéologie
du libre échange n'était absolument pas
bien et est un marché de dupes et lors
le le problème c'est que c'est que les
les occidentaux se sont mis à croire au
propre fable qu'ils à kiel qui
propageaient pour les autres ce que les
auteurs ont appelé la stratégie retrait
de l'esha bien nous on a réussi grâce au
protectionnisme mais maintenant qu'il
faut qu on exporte en produits
manufacturés
on va les les va interdire aux autres de
suivre le même chemin bon et donc il
faut qu'ils achètent nos produits vins
du secteur alors donc allumé
reconstruire c'est encore plus complexe
puisque c'est un accord de libre échange
entre l'union européenne et une union
douanière qu'elle mercosur et dans cette
union douanière il ya déjà des
phénomènes de développement inégal
notamment entre l'argentine et le brésil
est une grande puissance exportatrice de
produits nos produits non mais les
factures et de 2,9 à lui pris alors
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce qui risque
effectivement de se passer abbas qui a
une destruction de l'environnement bien
évidemment parce qu'on n'avale pas
surexploitation mais alors la pourquoi
sa maquette l'occident cette histoire
d'environnement qui vient un petit peu
comme les cheveux sur la soupe
ça fait très bien ça va être très
politiquement correct mais quand nous
avons lancé la mode
la consommation du quinoa qui détruit la
polyculture des paysans andins les
écosystèmes des paysans des personnes ne
s'en affoler parce que le quidam assez
sympa quand on est on a profité des
exportations chinoises qui détruisent
l'environnement chinois parce qu'on a
besoin de leurs terres rares pour
fabriquer nos téléphones et ça ne
scandalise absolument personne donc à la
effectivement cet échange est inégale la
question de savoir qu'il faudrait
creuser plus avant c'est de savoir si le
brésil l'argentine et les grands pays
qui font partie de mercosur ont des
stratégies de développement industriel
qui vont permettre l'absorption de
technologies occidentales pour
développer une industrie nationale
c'est ce que proposait d'ailleurs
l'économiste argentin a une très vive
dans les années 60 est là qui dirigeait
la lah du sed donc à ce moment là s'ils
se met à fabriquer des voitures s'y
développent une industrie performante et
bien cet accord va devenir très très
fortement déséquilibrée l'orne où le
client sait que le ce prétexte
environnemental et de circonstance c'est
que quand on sait plus bas faire on veut
pas dire les choses crûment au sort
l'environnement merci merci beaucoup à
claude rochet relance besoin de plus de
temps pour continuer trois discussions
merci nous avons un carnet sur ce sujet
je vous rappelle que vous êtes
économiste et directeur de recherches à
l'université paris dauphine